gonna meet your chick and we're gonna
get married in the virtual world how
about that and then she was gay
we'll see who makes out better
[Music]
everybody loves a really good loophole
um yeah loopholes China has the king of
loopholes yeah I might say China has
banned women from modeling lingerie on
online shopping lives it's good loophole
so men are now modeling them on online
even better
is good that's
that's really the their names Nick and
Charlie
it's funny how they specifically banned
women they didn't just say you can't
model lingerie
oh my god well you know what though
what's the point though is it one of the
top selling people on China live stream
a dude and he sells Women's Cosmetics I
think so yeah he's like the number one
it's like like a billion Shopping
Network style they live stream shopping
got it yeah it's like a new style of
like so they probably just do big
numbers
because I've seen my wife she follows
like these designer purse people you
know and they do that kind of style of
selling yeah like on a live stream and
they do crazy what do you mean falling
designer purse people like like Prada
[__] Gucci whatever the [__] fancy
and then they live streams live stream
like hey I got this it's a vintage bag
it's a [__] 2000. it's like pop shop
yeah and they do crazy numbers and
that's like China's like number one way
of like sales right now right yeah they
do crazy stuff like that their entire
e-commerce like industry is ridiculous
that's just crazy that even in China in
a place like that like the number one
seller for women's stuff is a dude I
mean now it's for sure the number 10. I
mean that guys just sell things better
right are feminists up in arms about
this yeah but they're still not buying
from women so it's fine like that is a
cute lingerie set also not going to WNBA
games
they should make this the recruiting
commercial you know how we're down in
recruiting numbers like do you want to
see this show on your [__] TV if not
go sign up we can fight and fight a warm
yeah because if they take us over we're
gonna be seeing this [__] yeah
where the [__]
the [__] [__] on channel 18. some guy
with no tits what's the point of fact
channel 18 is mostly Korean we don't do
this no it's Chinese and Indian and
Vietnamese
yeah sometimes it's hollow hollow TV
channel 18. it's like all the Asians
share it the Philippines like to see
this [__] on my [__] YouTube ads you
don't want to see guys in dressing
teddies no I think it's a pretty novel
way though of selling it
because women I don't know maybe they
would rather see a dude in it well they
probably want to see how it fits so it's
not like you know it's just for them I
think it's like Victoria Chain's secret
and then they're like what are we gonna
do about our business man they're like I
know they just said no girls right and
then they're just they're like The Show
Must Go On they get the [__] guy in
the back hey hey ciao come over here he
goes huh so then are we or like they
saying then that oh yeah men like
because women like to see what it looks
like they picture their bodies or they
sending women in China have bodies of
the men in China I didn't say it he said
it wow I did say it yeah I said hey but
those guys
they have like a coat hanger-esque body
you know what I mean like they have
pretty they got nice bodies so you're
saying if you wear a coat it's just
gonna fall off they have no shoulders
they're slender they're slender they got
fair skin you know what I mean they
don't want to see that [__] you don't be
funny I want to see a real man model
lingerie
chick do it you know that if there was a
bunch of buff ass dudes Bart would watch
for a while he's like oh that guy has a
great lats you know what I like how this
strap barely covers his nipple it might
be if the main audience and the
customers are women right like they
still like men so they're it's not for
us so maybe this is even better yeah
that's what I was thinking because
that's like a fetish for them yeah
because when I when I'm thinking about
shopping for clothes and then I'm like I
don't see no guys you know let me see a
girl like put on the Kirkland sweatshirt
you're so straight it's crazy and I'm
like dude
you're the straightest guy I've ever met
I'm gonna be like you man when I'm
trying to buy clothes I want to see a
guy who kind of looks like me so I could
be like okay does this fit okay nah why
would you want to see a freak like that
you you are so gay Nick yeah well you're
so straight how about that you're
[__] straight because the reason why
I have so many women on my Instagram
feed is because I aspire to have looks
like that I'm so straight I wanna I
wanna look like a beautiful over 50 of
it you're on your way hair wise yeah let
me get this straight for lack of a
better word you want you're saying your
desire to wear clothes like a woman is
what attracts women to you yeah I like
women so much that I wanna
[Laughter]
well I mean like how straight are you
anyway if you're looking at guys all day
that's true that's true that's why
Nick is the gayest one here he's
studying Jiu Jitsu
fighting men all day long I've watched a
lot of dudes did select a martial art
that there's the most body body to body
contact consistency it shows him
technically not only that they're
wrapping their legs around each other
all day long they start in the
missionary position yeah do you get
Escape points in Jiu Jitsu I don't
believe in Escape point I knew I need I
need chest to chest yeah I need I need
our bellies to touch a little bit are
you from the school of like why wear
uniforms
or what's it called just make it yeah
yeah actually after hours it's called
spaghetti and meatballs we want to
mishmash Parts you know if that's what
you're into you can trace belt and he
wraps it around the other guy's body too
I see if I ask Mike song dude he knows
putting Mike onto it it's our God you
have a 69 League where you guys start
but is it is that one of my best
positions yeah I mean because you did
mention you haven't had you could do 96
you haven't had coitus in quite some
time so I feel like maybe this might be
because I'm too tired when I go home
from training Jiu Jitsu all day it's
redundant are you the kind of guy that
when you play
um when you play like games right you
choose a man character and a buff guy I
make a buff yeah I make them six foot
yeah yeah see I always I always choose a
sexy girl because I like my character to
be eye candy that I'm watching all the
time and when you're in those worlds and
you're a sexy girl guys are so simp dude
dude you know what maybe give you so
much [__] oh like you're ever playing
like Elder Scrolls or something yep and
then you're a girl character you're in a
[__] world they come up they just
start throwing gifts at you yeah but in
those games you gotta you marry a man so
who's straight now yeah
Nick wants to put like you know be the
man and you want to be the girl that's
talking to men so it's like I'm confused
he's catfishing men
I think it's uh neutral at this point
you should just meet in the Ready Player
One World today a Black Mirror yeah I'm
gonna meet your chick and we're gonna
get married in the virtual world how
about that and then yes he was gay
we'll see what makes out better
I'll put you to the test yeah dude and
then when you take out the VR headsets
you're like did I just do that with Joe
yeah yeah yeah
don't tell Bart it's gonna be weird at
work and [__] now it's just like what
are you doing nothing are you playing
with Joe again I was like no I heard his
voice
why does it sound like that this reminds
me of the loophole on Twitch where where
they're like yeah you can't be in like
swimsuits unless you're like in a pool
so they're like this is the opposite so
then they all built hot tubs in their
freaking bed but it became huge right it
became an entire [__] like sub
category that's like one of the largest
categories in the entire twitch platform
so they can't wear swimsuits on unless
it makes sense yeah yeah you can't wear
like like um you can't wear lingerie so
and and you can only wear something like
a bathing suit if you're in a pool so
all these kiddie pools or stuff all of
them bought kiddie pools and put them in
their living rooms in their bedrooms or
something you literally have a blow up
pool wow and they're just [__]
Heavies and that's that's the loophole
but it but it became so successful and
it like really I made it better oh the
loophole so well that they have an
entire like subcategory because they're
trying to ban like sexy time twitch and
then they found the loophole to do the
sexy time twitch I'm assuming that like
twitch like was like okay like from a
legal point of view like we have to do
this but then it's like oh it's still
working but it's the rules so it's
better yeah which is why which is why
only fans is only fans right like it
makes sense because that's what you can
do there that type of content so you
can't do that on Twitch unless I've been
seeing nude girls on Instagram because
they have these interesting dresses now
that basically you could see everything
but it's fishnet yeah so I'm like what
the [__] how did this pop up on my feed
there's a lot of Trends right now where
they like well they'll be topless but
you see it through the reflection of
something yeah wow it's like a trend
where girls like they found ways that it
won't get detected what's the hashtag
Ryan I don't know I'm gay
you know what it is
if you want to see nudity on Instagram
instead of outright following these like
models what you would like to do is
follow meme Pages because they pay meme
Pages oh yeah to advertise collabs and
that's why they pop out of nowhere and
you got to go to the really like dark
meme Pages like the ones that like it
you see you know it's just really funny
[__] to see this yeah am I am I just out
of touch and just really old can you
just go on Google and type tits yeah but
then who does that you feel always what
are you a dinosaur you're so thirsty do
you know how you do it okay I didn't
know I didn't but the surprise is kind
of cool you know you're at a park bench
you can type surprise to it no no
because there's there's something weird
in the in the psyche of like going to a
porn site to get it versus being on like
the largest platform from social media
and it's just and you're like whoa this
is this must be allowed therefore I'm
not a creep it's a stupid ass [__] IG
really turned up the the tick tock did
you notice that yeah it's all real ig's
been becoming more I mean in terms of
like making you see eat chicks oh it's
like way overboard right now well I
think just because we're all dudes like
the algorithm they just send it no
you're you always want to see just guys
right nah but even on my stuff like
there's guys there's a girl that pops up
yeah always and it's like I follow a
bunch of even on my side even on my
stuff even like all the meme pages right
like my algorithm is like dogs Jiu Jitsu
stuff hospital but then a girl will pop
up yeah
how mad do you get when that happens
dude I get so [__] pissed I got so
[__] pissed dude I almost broke my
phone the other day and that's all we're
gonna say because now it's 11 minutes
thank you